cet après midi nathalie tauziat été
battu par la numéro 3 mondial ne votent
na en deux sets la première française
aller en finale a dû s'incliner devant
la tchèque après la victoire de l'équipe
de france les bleus se sont retrouvés à
clairefontaine il se prépare à affronter
l'équipe victorieuse qui jouera ce soir
à lyon tout à l'heure les pays bas se
sont imposés contre l'argentine 2 1
l'autoroute des vacances bison futé
prévoyait un samedi rouge la circulation
est moins dense que prévu de sérieux
ralentissements mais pas de gros
bouchons dans la vallée du rhône
notamment la mode avec les défilés du
prêt-à-porter masculin aujourd'hui c'est
l'anglais paul smith qui présentait sa
collection une touche très britannique
est très moderne à la fois madame
monsieur bonsoir je vous le dise en
titre nathalie tauziat la première
française à disputer une finale à
wimbledon depuis soixante présents et
passés tout près d'un rêve improbable
battre la tchèque novotna troisième
mondial cet après midi au terme d'une
partie rapide
la française a perdu en deux sets 6 4 7
6 christelle bertrand on ne sait pas ce
que la duchesse de kent et gagnent à
nouveau tenace raconte
mais une chose est sûre elles sont
contentes de se retrouver à partouzes ya
qui essuient une défaite tout le monde
est heureux de voir la tchèque remporté
à 29 ans son premier tournoi du grand
chelem et sa mère plus que tous les
autres
la française ne pouvait pourtant pas
mieux commencer le match
elle mène rapidement 2-0 dosia
solide précis mais ce n'est pas
suffisant pour faire douter novotna la
tchèque qui a toujours eu du mal à
maîtriser ses nerfs fait craquer la
française novotna a juste servi un peu
mieux retourner un peu mieux et volleye
un cran au dessus j'ai rien à regretter
je pense que pour ma première finale
d'un grand chelem j'ai joué le jeu j'ai
j'ai raté quelques occasions c'est vrai
mais bon je pouvais aussi leurs atouts
premier tour et me retrouver dehors je
gère un temps final pas mal pas mal mais
pas assez pour gagner nos votes renard
s'impose 6 4 7 6 au bout d'une heure et
demie de tension elle peut enfin se
laisser aller de via il va aussi de son
petit tour d'honneur elle repart avec
son plateau de finaliste en ne perdant
pas de vue celui du vainqueur
cg rue remis trophées fait partie remise
pour l'année prochaine
yana novotna chérit son premier trophée
dans un tournoi du grand chelem
avec cette victoire c'est une place de
numéro deux mondial qu'elle s'offre sur
un plateau
j'en viens maintenant au départ sur les
routes des vacances bonne surprise pour
les automobilistes après une matinée
chargée la circulation est à nouveau
devenu fluide malgré les prévisions très
alarmiste du centre national
d'information routière
ce samedi était classée rouge mais fort
heureusement aucun bouchons
inextricables dans la vallée du rhône où
nous retrouvons virginie fichiers et
philippe rivet image bucolique ici dans
l'atmosphère flotte un parfum de
vacances pourtant le camping est encore
loin et l'autoroute n'est qu'à quelques
mètres
nous sommes sur la première aire de
repos de l'autoroute du soleil
on connaît ça depuis robes ou de 10 ans
environ
cet endroit vous arrêtez de toujours ici
qu'un jour le jour après des heures de
route les automobilistes ankylosé
savoure ici les premières joies de l'été
ce tour a dû fait trop chaud pendant que
certains transpire au volant d'autres
payent de leur sueur le confort du
voyageur fatigués ils sont une
cinquantaine de saisonniers sur
l'autoroute chargés de l'entretien pour
eux aussi cette journée a été longue
je sais qu'ils soient toujours propre
c'est difficile mais on essaie de faire
de mieux
beaucoup de présence oui on est là douze
heures par jour mines exprès matin une
équipe l'après midi sur l'autoroute a7
plus de 70 mille véhicules sont
descendus vers le sud aujourd'hui le
long de lax
la gendarmerie avait doublé ses
effectifs mais les bouchons tant redouté
se sont finalement résumé à quelques
gros ralentissements très localisés et
surtout très ponctuel c'est ainsi qu'est
la surprise générale une journée rouge
virale orange simplement peut-être
l'effet coupe du monde
peut-être que il y avait tellement des
départs
en convient et compte tenu que les
enfants ont succombé depuis le premier
certains candidats bacheliers non les
vacances que la semaine prochaine
résultat dès le milieu de l'après midi
les vacanciers pressés ont pu profiter
pleinement de l'autoroute du soleil
une fois encore l'appel à la prudence
pour tous ceux qui prennent le volant
cette nuit près de cholet un grave
accident lors d'un dépassement jugé
dangereux a provoqué la mort de cinq
jeunes âgés de 18 à 25 ans le choc a été
d'une extrême violence passage des
conducteurs ont été tuées sur le coup
une sixième victime est dans un état
grave
on ignore si la vitesse et l'alcool sont
en cause on parle beaucoup ces jours-ci
de la reprise de la consommation en
france une bonne nouvelle pour les
hôteliers et les agences de voyages qui
voit se dessiner une saison touristique
prometteuse
l'exemple de palavas dans l'hérault la
station balnéaire attire dès ses
premiers jours de juillet de nombreux
vacanciers
le running gag l'yonne pascal pense la
résidence de leurs vacances ils l'ont
rêvé sur des pliants depuis des mois et
puis voilà il ne leur manque que les
clés ils étaient nombreux après des
heures de voiture à attendre cet après
midi devant le bureau de location à
palavas le studio à plus de 2000 francs
la semaine
seul ou bien juillet s'annonce comme en
juillet oui à l'office de tourisme on
appelle deux fois par jour les hôtels de
la ville est apparue une semaine un peu
creuse depuis la fin des matches à
montpellier on peut dire que les
affaires vont bien les touristes
arrivent
il vous reste que deux plats peu de
champ parfait mais je vous remercie
beaucoup bonne journée à ce soir à voir
comment s'annonce la saison très très
bien très bien il fait très beau
pas de vin les touristes arrivent et il
y a même des hôteliers face à la mer qui
affichent leur satisfaction
ça dépend les soirs suivants les séjours
entre les deux on a des fois une ou deux
chambres de vite mais sans quoi tout est
réservé jusqu'au 15 septembre à peu près
en languedoc roussillon deux entreprises
touristiques sur trois déclarent
travailler au moins aussi bien que l'an
dernier
voilà donc une saison prometteuse que
les professionnels espèrent rien ne
viendra gâtés
la france est vous le savez l'une des
premières destinations touristiques au
monde la bretagne chaque année attire
une clientèle étrangère à majorité
britanniques comme dans ce camping près
de dol de bretagne où 80 % des touristes
ont traversé la manche jacques devaux
gabriel camilla ici il ya même un
terrain de cricket
un petit bout d'angleterre perdue dans
la campagne bretonne un camping 4
étoiles où nos policiers parlent et
britten
au coeur de l'été
ils seront jusqu'à 3000 à fréquenter les
lieux 80% de la clientèle ce qui n'est
pas toujours très dépaysant on venait
juste d'arriver
on allait à l'accueil et là on a
rencontré un autre irlandais omar sy et
il était juste derrière nous
en vingt ans le domaine des ormes a bâti
sa renommée outreman golf équitation
pêche piscine ont séduit des
britanniques une clientèle réputé
exigeante
c'est pour les familles c'est pour les
enfants c'est cinq questions de sécurité
pour les enfants les parents sont
contents si les enfants sont onéreuses
dans la nourriture
l'accueil et le service sont excellents
du coup l'omniprésence des citoyens
britanniques avaient fui les français
les français donc il ya ni citron tient
pas assez de français il reste et
pendant deux mois le domaine va vivre
sous les couleurs britanniques une
invasion qui s'ils ne gêne personne
depuis jeudi les côtes d'armor et la
loire atlantique ont interdit la pêche
des coquillages impropre à la
consommation car ils sont devenus
toxiques en raison d'une halle que le
dinophysis c'est aujourd'hui au tour de
la préfecture du morbihan de mettre en
garde les estivants contre le ramassage
de ces coquillages laurent le job le
dinophysis et peut-être microscopiques
mais il est le cauchemar des amateurs de
fruits de mer
ce plancton toxique s'accumulent dans
les coques les palourdes et les moules
l'homme qui consomment ensuite ces
coquillages souffre d'un manque ablement
de gastro entérite et de maux de tête
tous les ans à la même saison le
dinophysis prolifèrent en bretagne et
l'on ne connaît toujours aucun moyen de
l'en empêcher
c'est une nouvelle tout à fait naturel
malheureusement on ne peut rien faire
pour son débat c'est donc ce qu'il faut
c'est cheville et will show et en tirer
les conséquences le plan pratique des
décisions pratiques ont donc une fois de
plus était prise interdiction de
ramasser ses coquillages dans les zones
en jaune sur ses cartes le morbihan la
loire-atlantique le finistère et les
côtes d'armor sont concernés ce genre
d'interdiction est en général levé au
bout de deux semaines le temps pour le
dinophysis de disparaître comme il est
venu naturellement
elle redit ce n'est la grève d'une
partie des salariés se poursuit après
les animateurs en costume les
techniciens du spectacle rejoignent ce
mouvement avec des revendications
portant notamment sur la revalorisation
des compétences et l'augmentation des
salaires malgré des piquets de grève la
fameuse parade a bien lieu cet après
midi mais les chars n'étaient pas tout à
fait au complet
les négociations avec la direction se
sont déroulés toute cette journée
martine aubry ministre de la solidarité
de l'emploi devrait annoncer lundi un
programme d'actions pour l'assurance
maladie alors que le conseil d'état
vient de porter un sérieux coup à la
réforme juppé puisque hier les
magistrats ont annulé la convention des
médecins généralistes les explications
nécessaires jean yves perrin la
convention entre les médecins
généralistes et la sécu adulé par le
conseil d'état un nouveau revers pour le
plan juppé
la décision du conseil d'état porte en
effet sur deux points importants de
cette réforme du système de santé
décidée en novembre 95 en premier lieu
le statut de médecin référent est remise
en cause
il ne sera donc plus possible de
s'abonner chez le généraliste de son
choix et de bénéficier ainsi des
facilités de paiement seconde
disposition contestée
les modalités de calcul des sanctions
financières appliquées aux médecins qui
dérape
cette annulation ne doit pas affecter le
remboursement des assurés sociaux
elle intervient alors que les dépenses
de santé vérifie à nouveau le déficit de
la sécu pourrait s'alourdir de cinq
milliards supplémentaires si de
nouvelles mesures ne sont pas rapidement
prises
martine aubry ministre de la solidarité
doit annoncer lundi
un programme d'actions pour l'assurance
maladie il viserait certaine catégorie
de médecins particulièrement dépensiers
comme les radiologistes et les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques les
universités d'été du rpr nicolas sarkozy
et devant les jeunes du mouvement les
invite à prendre la place de ceux qui
sont fatigués alain juppé pour raisons
personnelles a annoncé qu'il ne
participerait pas ce rendez vous placé
sous le signe de l'unité de la famille
volus et de la pugnacité de l'opposition
l'algérie avec la résistance de la
kabylie à l'arabisation qui devrait
entrer en vigueur dès demain après les
émeutes qui ont secoué la région cette
semaine une marche de plusieurs milliers
d'étudiants ce matin à tizi ouzou
principale ville de kabylie où vivaient
lounès matoub assassiné il ya dix jours
demain un appel à la grève générale et
d'autres rassemblements sont prévus y
compris dans le centre d'alger
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
thierry thulliez bruno girodon la ville
ne s'est pas encore remise des émules de
la semaine dernière qu'elle doit se
préparer à une nouvelle journée de
manifestations à un commerce de 18
journées ouvert quand la marche des
étudiants empreinte la vendre du son et
slogans choc sans ambiguïté
zeroual le président algérien et le
pouvoir sont qualifiés d'assassins
depuis la mort de lunesse matoub les
accusations des manifestants n'ont pas
changé nous il émerge désormais aussi
une revendication identitaire
cet après midi on apercevait dans le
cortège des banderoles en berbère mais
le manifestants ne sont pas seuls c'est
toute la ville qui refuse la
généralisation de l'arabe au détriment
contre les vers les autres nations du
monde
il faut qu'on s'ouvre vers les autres
langues nous avons toujours vécu avec
les autres langues
nous avons comment dire les gens
apprennent les dialectes maintenant le
suisse simon face au froid ne sont pas
déjà c'est pas vrai on a besoin d'un
précieux radiations c'est seulement par
wifi scène ml est une de ces
associations on apprend à mazille
autrement dit la langue berbère celle
les premiers habitants de l'algérie
avant les réalisations de la région un
tiers des algériens le parlerait encore
aujourd'hui elle est là qu est ce que
vous leur demandez lorsque je lui ai dit
qu'est ce que tu m as their c'est existe
c'est vraiment ma part mangue maternelle
c'est vraiment que tu lises algérie
pas question de s'exprimer en arabe et
la nouvelle loi ne sera pas appliquée ce
sera leur manière de résister partout en
kabylie une société parallèle s'est
ainsi constitué grâce aux associations
les jeunes apprennent à travailler à
penser et à chanter en berbère avec
l'espoir qu'un jour leur langue sera
reconnue officiellement en algérie au
même titre que l'arabe
en turquie de nouvelles secousses se
sont produites dans la province d'adana
réplique qu'on violent tremblement de
terre qui a fait la semaine dernière 144
morts et plus de 1500 blessés d'après un
dernier bilan aujourd'hui
une première secousse a frappé la région
tout ce matin près d'un millier de
personnes ont été légèrement blessées
puis trois nouvelles autres secousses
une faible amplitude se sont succédé
sans faire de victime
depuis plusieurs semaines l'ethiopie et
l'erythrée se sont engagés dans un
conflit frontalier dont on voit mal ni
su hier le rwanda qui faisait partie du
comité de médiation se retirer je tends
de nouvelles incertitudes sur le plan de
paix américano au rwanda ce conflit
entre deux frères ennemis bouleverse la
vie de toute une population contrainte à
l'exil chasse et de l'erythrée voisine
plusieurs milliers d'éthiopiens ont tout
perdu reportage de notre équipe sur
place
éric meunier france vaillants ils sont
éthiopiens et viennent d'arriver dans
leur pays
chassés de l'erythrée voisine où ils
s'étaient installés certains depuis
plusieurs années il y avait fondé une
famille ils disent qu'ils y vivent est
heureux avant que la guerre entre
ethiopie erythrée n'éclate en mai
dernier
depuis tout a changé brimades
arrestation et finalement expulsion les
déportés comme on les appelle ici au
nord de l'ethiopie ont tout perdu il
leur faut compter désormais sur les
rations de la solidarité nationale comme
des réfugiés dans leur propre pays
ils m'ont tout pris je suis arrivé en
ethiopie en sous vêtements ce pantalon
c'est quelqu'un qui me l'a dit je vais
devoir vivre ici maintenant et manger
j'ai une femme érythréenne depuis dix
ans franchement je ne pensais pas
j'étais à l'église à smara avec mon
petit chien chercher monte expulsé
je n'ai même pas pu dire au revoir à mes
enfants et mon mari
selon le gouvernement éthiopien 4000 de
ses ressortissants ont ainsi été expulsé
toujours en ethiopie à une centaine de
kilomètres plus au sud mais qu'elle est
capitale de la province du tigré
attendant l'angoissent la reprise des
hostilités
ici une bombe érythréenne a laissé un
trou dans le toit d'une école 48 mans
dans cette ville beaucoup d'erythréens
possède des affaires comme le script nos
photos sous rafael une institution à
mesquer évoqué la guerre met mal à
l'aise on préfère ne pas trop s'exposer
non les clients se comportent comme
avant ça va bien pour nous
et ceux qui viennent vous parle de la
guerre
non non non non le consulat d'erythrée à
mais qu'elle est désormais ferme
l'ethiopie a procédé elle aussi à des
expulsions avec plus de discernement
semble-t-il quiros l'asnl m s'est
retrouvé seul avec ses cinq enfants son
mari entrepreneur érythréens accusées
d'apporter une aide financière à
l'ennemi a été prié de quitter le pays
je suis désolé de cette situation
ce n'est pas seulement mon mari qui est
déporté c'est le problème de ces deux
pays frères qui se font la guerre et qui
peuvent se détruire ici avec elle et
plusieurs personnes ont été arrêtées
les personnes soupçonnées de renseigner
par radio les erythréens entre les deux
peuples
la confiance a disparu quelle que soit
l'issue de la guerre plus rien ne sera
comme avant en irlande du nord des
centaines de policiers de soldats ont
bloqué les points stratégiques autour de
la ville de port d'aden où doit se
dérouler demain la marche protestante
organisé chaque année près de belfast ce
premier test pour la paix en irlande du
nord inquiète le premier ministre
britannique et irlandais car les
orangistes se disent prêts à passer
outre l'interdiction de traverser l'une
des rues catholique de la ville
le mouvement des mineurs ukrainien qui
depuis plusieurs semaines s'insurge
contre le gouvernement qui n'a pas tenu
ses engagements
les salaires sont toujours impayées
devant le kremlin ces mineurs campent
depuis près d'un mois et menace
d'installer un piquet de grève gilles
rabin franck brisset ils sont là
maintenant depuis 21 jours au pied de
l'immeuble du gouvernement
la maison blanche de moscou ils ne
réclament pas seulement les salaires on
ne leur paye plus ils veulent que les
thérapeutiques le boris eltsine sans
mind l'armée est avec moi tout le monde
nous soutient même les flics quand on
leur parle ils disent tous il faut en
finir la solidarité quotidienne ils
n'ont plus d'argent
le petit peuple de moscou mais nourrit
on a donné nos derniers sous bien qu'une
retraite ne soient pas payés j'ai pas
touché mon mois donné chaque jour au
début de chaque heure et rappelé sol en
scandant y aussi une démission depuis 21
jours la maison blanche reste sourde
mais les mineurs ne serait ce pas vous
pouvez voir ici et là les splendeurs et
les misères de la démocratie pour les
mineurs la nouvelle démocratie russe
n'est qu'une courte design qui
prospèrent à leurs dépens et quand
iossif kobzon chanteur populaire et
député proulx eltsine vient les voir ils
n'applaudissent que le chanteur
le passage à l'économie de marché aura
coûté trop cher ça fait dix ans et dix
ans c'est long certains en pleurs
presque d'autres font mine d'henry mais
tous sont persuadés que le pays tout
entier va se lever à tcheliabinsk
les mineurs se sont mis en grève
asnières cas aussi il coupe le
transsibérien leur calme ne doit pas
tromper
ils sont déterminés à aller jusqu'au
bout jusqu'à l'arrêt des réformes
économiques et la démission boris
eltsine même s'ils savent que la
bataille est presque perdu par ans aux
états unis qui célèbrent aujourd'hui le
jour de l'indépendance les feux
d'artifice ont été interdits en floride
est victime de violents incendies qui
ont déjà ravagé plus de cent mille
hectares aujourd'hui après des pluies
d'orage les flammes ont perdu de leur
intensité mais les pompiers restent sur
le qui vive
richard binet
la floride vue du ciel comme un
spectacle de guerre et au sol la
désolation un véritable désastre
écologique 180 mille hectares de forêts
ravagées par les flammes
et soudain ce matin comme une trêve
l'appui providentiel est enfin arrivé le
vent est tombé un répit pour les 3000
pompiers qui depuis cinq semaines plus
tôt contre le feu notre plus grand
problème aujourd'hui c'est la résistance
des hommes nos confié travail 13 36 48
heures sans interruption ils sont
épuisés soulagement provisoire hier le
feu gagnait encore et encore du terrain
par milliers d américains fuyaient la
région tandis qu'une épaisse couche de
fumée recouvrait le nord-est de la
floride forçant l'évacuation de plus de
cent mille personnes
aujourd'hui les pompiers tentent de
circonscrire les derniers foyers à
l'aide de canons à eau et d'hélicoptères
il faut agir vite en floride
la météo est imprévisible le feu peut
reprendre à tout moment
la canicule en italie 45 degrés en
sicile rome est également touchée par
cette vague de chaleur qui s'étend à la
grèce ou à athènes la pollution qui
s'ajoute à l'air étouffant de la
capitale a provoqué des dizaines de
spécialisation c'est le troisième jour
consécutif que cette canicule frappe la
grèce les services d'urgence sont
débordés par ailleurs de violents
incendies touchent le pays plus d'une
dizaine de foyers attisés par des vents
violents dans les forêts les maquis du
pays placées en état d' alerte maximum
les pompiers du feu soutenu par des
canadairs tente de venir à bout des
flammes au tour au mondial l'équipe de
france après sa victoire hier contre
l'italie savoure son succès avec cette
interrogation les tricolores ont su
mener la partie mais sans marquer de but
yann lavoix en benjamin laurent blanc
taquine lizarazu n'a eu peur après avoir
manqué son penalty lui dit il
et c'est ainsi que la vie reprend son
cours à clairefontaine chacun se plaît à
se retrouver les lendemains de match ne
serait ce que pour échanger des idées et
de ce côté-là thuram est au rendez vous
comme sur le terrain depuis le début de
la coupe du monde il s'est révélé être
un vrai patron au point qu'il surprend
même ses coéquipiers le connaissent
depuis plusieurs années mais tarde
toujours à manger des salades et des fal
la salade voilà peut-être le secret de
la réussite celui qui permettrait aux
attaquants de retrouver le chemin des
filets un seul but marqué en deux
matches avec prolongation est-ce que
c'est grave docteur
à ce toujours pour nous quelque chose
qui nous interpelle
mais ça serait grave pour nous si on ce
site si on se crée pas des situations de
l'offensive lancée créé se crée des
situations aussi évidente face à
l'équipe italienne faut des jarres est
assez costaud mais oui en fait c'est le
stress ressenti lors des deux derniers
matches qui nous fait oublier les débuts
déjà inscrits par la france en cinq
rencontres de coupe du monde et le jeune
henry nous remet d'ailleurs les idées en
place d'ailleurs c'est un match défense
défense même si j'ai quand même beaucoup
d'occasions je pense que des deux côtés
mais on a pu voir aussi virer me sens
mieux avant elle a toujours marqué et il
ya la remarque et donc serait cas pas
que l'équipe de france non plus bien sûr
du coup nous voilà plein d'espoir pour
les demi finales que les français
voudraient jouer face à qui au fait
la croatie ou l'allemagne tout le monde
pense qu'on va jouer les allemands parce
que je pense que tout le monde veut qu
en joue les allemands les allemands bon
c'est vrai que ça permettra un petit
papier pour vous mais disons que c'est
quand même une équipe qui reste très
dangereuse et et et
il faut s'en méfier en fait allemand
croit qu importe maintenant pourvu qu'il
y ait du bresse et la danse du jacquet
ils nous rejoignent maintenant a lieu en
direct du stade de gerland florent
gautreau doit se dérouler dans moins
d'une demi heure le match allemagne
croatie russe est le vainqueur de ce
match rencontrera la france en demi
finale l'allemagne on a compris part
favorite et l'équipe de france regardera
avec beaucoup d'attention les faiblesses
et les forces de ces deux équipes l'an
oui les français surveilleront de près
les crois tu qu'ils ne connaissent pas
ces croates peuvent créer la surprise
parce qu'ils n'ont plus rien à perdre
ils ont déjà rempli leur contrat en
atteignant les quarts de finale de la
coupe du monde et c'est croate qui
s'échauffe ont une mentalité
particulière je parlerais même d'un
patriotisme fédérateur qui anime les
représentants de l'ex yougoslavie de ce
pays de l'ex yougoslavie mais en face il
y à l'allemagne et nul doute que les
défenseurs français desailly lizarazu
convient de voir regarderont et
examineront le jeu des deux attaquants
vedettes klinsmann et bierhoff qui ont
déjà inscrit chacun trois buts depuis le
début de ce mondial
alors évidemment on attend tous le choc
france allemagne mais rien n'est fait
allemagne ou croatie ça va se décider à
l'est dans deux ou trois heures je pense
que les français sont effectivement
devant leur écran de télévision pour
connaître leurs futurs adversaires
merci florent cet après midi à marseille
au stade de vélodrome les pays-bas se
sont qualifiés pour les demi finales
face à l'argentine de busards au
prochain tour ils affronteront le brésil
résumé du match alexandre kara en
football il y à des têtes dont on se
passerait bien des mauvais gestes pas du
tout technique mais totalement stupide
qui mérite bien un carton rouge sur le
terrain ortega c'est docteur jekyll et
mister hyde
capable du meilleur et du pire dommage
le pire on n'était pas vraiment habitué
d'autant plus dommage que depuis le
début de ce match
les grands avaient montré le bon exemple
pays bas argentine
la belle affiche un match de premier de
la classe sans vouloir donner de leçon
voilà une rencontre où l'on n'a pas peur
de jouer la tacc de jouer pour marquer
les oranges pressées d'ouvrir le score
se montre dominateur
la tête de de boer les jambes de creil
vert c'est un duo de choc échec au roi
le gardien argentin est battu le bleu
ciel et blanc ne tarde pas à réagir
une ouverture inspirée de vérone et
c'est lopez qui pend son temps pour
tromper van der sar dans les tribunes on
a sorti les mouchoirs
voilà un garçon qui a du talent sur son
maillot d'autant plus que l'histoire se
répète comme face à l'angleterre les
argentins ou à l'équipe adverse
réduite à dix avec l'expulsion de
neumann on se dit alors qu'elle est la
table sont cuits mais il n'en est rien
après l'expulsion d'ortega les deux
équipes sont à égalité un expulsé par
tous mais dennis bergkamp fait la
différence à quelques minutes de la fin
du match
l'argentine est à terre les néerlandais
tiennent leur revanche
vingt ans après leur défaite en finale
du mondial à buenos aires en demi finale
les oranje eux rencontreront les jeunes
du brésil des hollandais qui pleure pas
pour l'argentine mais pour la plus belle
des victoires
le mondial offre à certaines entreprises
l'occasion de faire leurs relations
publiques en invitant leurs clients dans
un pré carré installé au stade de france
d'un côté les gradins de l'autre côté
les loges et les allées feutrée pascal
golomer rejet motte
évidemment ça n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec les chants de supporters vous êtes
pourtant à quelques mètres de l'entrée
du stade de france
deux heures avant le match france italie
dans le village officiel
là où les 45 sponsor de la coupe du
monde accueillent leurs invités sésame
obligatoire autour du cou pour les 4000
heureux élus ambiance feutrée champagne
petits fours déjeuner en terrasse les
entreprises entendent bien choyés leurs
clients
quel qu'en soit le prix jusqu'à 1200
francs par personne sans les repas
mais rien de tel qu'un match de coupe du
monde pour entretenir de bonnes
relations
sans arrière pensée c'est promis là des
hommes d'affaires iliad et des gens
comme nous les joyeuses organisateurs et
on parle de philosophie en règle
générale pas oublier thomas de foot et
produit tout à faire ça resterait bien
oui on se connaît bien on discute aux
autres que prix catalogue de références
quantité promotions etc
pensez que c'est un bon point marqué par
philippa rapport à la concurrence cette
île de match mais c'est une prestation
en cherchant bien vous croiserez tout de
même au détour d'une allée quelques
vrais supporters et un sponsor interdits
de publicité autour des stades pour
cause d'une législation sur l'alcool
mais tout heureux de pouvoir s'afficher
ouvertement dans le village
va nous prendre soin de nos invités de
leur rendre leur voyage d'autant plus
agréable fin du match les français
sortent vainqueurs mais qu'importe au
village quelles que soient les qualifiés
on affiche complet
dix mille personnes bénéficiant d'un
accueil privilégié sont attendus
mercredi prochain au stade de france
pour la demi finale elle a vu cette
compétition inédite entre deux
véritables robots capables disputer un
match de football prodige de la
technique ils sont capables de penser le
jeu de développer leurs attaques
un spectacle est aussi une rencontre
mondiale entre laboratoires ultra
spécialisés frédéric renoue gens me
poussèrent les zidane mais barthez de
2018 se font sur des robots footballeurs
de 50 cm en pleine coupe du monde
comme leurs confrères humain le prochain
adversaire de la france l allemagne des
allemands bas de votre écran opposé au
japon quadrillage rigoureux du terrain
contre initiative premier ballon et
premier but du japon il faut arriver à
coordonner l'équipe réagir en temps réel
donc il faut traiter des informations
qui sont des informations réelles par le
biais de mes caméras ont croisé sa dans
un ordinateur on cherche un comportement
discute éventuellement et président si
on peut bien choisi une stratégie
attention on sait les robots car pendant
le match ils prennent leurs décisions
tout seul comme des grands
quitte à commettre des bourdes maîtres
comme ce défenseur allemand un but
contre son camp
on coupe du monde des robots
l'équivalent du brésil c'est cette
équipe américaine leur attaquant de
pointe s'appelle tout simplement diego
mais il n'a pas son sale caractère
il faudra encore attendre dix ou vingt
ans avant que chaque robot et sa propre
personnalité et qu'on puisse les
comparer à l'homme
le rouleau compresseur nippon lui
continue d'affoler la défense allemande
l'allemagne qui manque de rigueur c'est
le monde à l'envers
3 0 mais on n'est pas là pour s'amuser
faire jouer des robots tout seul au foot
c'est préparer des applications
autrement plus sérieuse si on arrive à
faire des colonie de robots
microscopiques moins une fois pour aller
guérir les gens c'est peut-être la
meilleure solution les injecte dans le
corps
si on leur dit ça se trouve la fouille
aller là qu'elles vont tenir là elles
vont faire leur travail qu'ils
apprennent vont sortir par un endroit
qu'on leur indiquera score final japon 4
allemagne 0 finalement en robot les
allemands sont peut-être à la portée des
français coup d'envoi des défilés de
prêt-à-porter masculin à paris en
vedette aujourd'hui l'anglais paul smith
internationalement connue pour son
savoir-faire très british adapté à l'ère
du temps paul smith un créateur qui a de
l'humour et de la fantaisie reportage ce
film et elle les dida ans
déshabiller les hommes pour mieux les
rhabiller
cet homme a fait fortune dans la mode
masculine aujourd'hui est le seul à
séduire david bowie mick jagger comme
tony blair son premier ministre ni
franchement industriel ni complètement
artistes paul smith a trouvé un bon
compromis
la tradition des tailleurs britannique
égayée par une légère touche de
fantaisie et de la recette fonctionne il
vend chaque année quelques 140 mille
costumes 500 mille chemises et autant de
cravate en un tour du monde et freiner
220 boutiques porte aujourd'hui son nom
ce sont les asiatiques qui raffole tout
particulièrement de son style
la dernière boutique en date la paul
smith house qui vient d'ouvrir ses
portes à londres dans un quartier
résidentiel est née d'un vieux rêve une
bâtisse bourgeoise sur trois étages un
lieu de vie plus qu'un simple lieu de
vente où se côtoient beaux livres objets
chinés et ateliers de costumes sur
mesure entièrement faits main pour le
créateur britannique vaut qu'un homme ne
doit chercher à suivre la mode de trop
près le rôle du vêtement servir une
personnalité et c'est l'attitude qui
fait toute la différence
je peux avoir beaucoup d'une nuit où je
peux être très sérieux je suis mr smith
je suis au centre de paris je suis très
honorés de vous accueillir le titien
suis un gentleman anglais où je peux
être mister bean monty python savez que
vous pouvez être utile vous voulez à
vous de choisir
lors de son dernier défilé présenté à
paris cet après midi une rencontre
imaginaire entre artistes et marchand
d'art une dégaine décontracté savamment
négligé pour séduire les plus jeunes ou
les plus libres mais aussi des costumes
de gentleman rassurant avec leurs coupes
cintrées qui force le maintien dans ce
milieu où la création a toujours été
opposé au marketing ou le talent est
suspecte quand il fait ménage avec un
empire commercial
paul smith a réussi un tour de force
dépasser les clivages
rendez vous pour les amateurs de jazz
avec le festival devienne une atmosphère
familiale où l'on aime vraiment la
musique un festival on ne se prend pas
au sérieux sauf sur scène louis carzou
grégoire rosina lorsque le jazz revient
prendre ses quartiers d'été dans les
arènes antique de vienne n'ont pas
question pour les viennois de faire la
java
car accueillir festivaliers techniciens
et musiciens
pour danièle lhomme en charge des
ventres affamés comme pour beaucoup
cette affaire d'importance aussi
importante qu'une passion c'est un lieu
qui accueille magique
puis il le fait d'avoir faire des
musiques avant ça me permet de voir des
gens que j'ai écouté temps genève
aujourd'hui je laissais
et tandis que taj mahal achève sa
répétition
daniel lui achève la préparation des
desserts du soir de quoi attendre et
même les blues man les plus endurcis
tous depuis 30 ans j'ai fait tous les
socialistes c'est toujours dans ce genre
d'endroit il yal'esprit sacro l'esprit
sacré c'est sûr car à l'heure de la
pause en milieu d'après midi daniel lui
en profite pour rejoindre le trio de son
fils au bar du commerce
le torna bas car la grande fierté du
restaurateur et d'être en plus le papa
d'un musicien force et oui pigeon tout
le monde doivent exercer
ça permet d'aller te pas garder un lien
avec le milieu musiciens et puis avec
toute cette ambiance du métier une
ambiance 100 pitite dix jours durant
pour daniel car ils poids serait la
tendance jusqu'au dernier accord
les avec des concerts comme celui de
blida alors comprend mieux que le public
et daniel n'ai aucune envie de réclamer
la dernière
avant de refermer ce journal cette
découverte des archéologues pensent
avoir découvert la plus vieille église
du monde l'église située à aqaba sur la
mer rouge a été enseveli sous le sable
lors d'un tremblement de terre est bien
conservé selon les premières estimations
le bâtiment construit en briques de
terre remontent au 3e siècle
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle les principaux titres
l'autoroute des vacances bison futé
prévoyait un samedi rouge la circulation
est moins dense que prévu de sérieux
ralentissements mais pas de gros
bouchons dans la vallée du rhône
notamment à wimbledon cet après-midi de
nathalie tauziat était battu par la
numéro 3 mondial ne veux tu na en deux
sets la première française aller en
finale a dû s'incliner devant la joueuse
tchèque
cet après-midi les pays bas se sont
imposés contre l'argentine 2 à 1 grâce à
un but dans les cinq dernières minutes
en demi finale les pays bas affronteront
le brésil dans un instant à la météo
laurent romejko je vous remercie de
votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2